[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale nous sommes le mercredi 13
novembre voici les titres le 17 novembre
2018 le mouvement des gilet jaune
débutait contre la hausse des prix du
carburant et la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat un an après quel est le bilan
auprès des personnes mobilisées la
réponse du gouvernement at-elle été
suffisante nous en parlons en plateau
une nouvelle équipe et un objectif la
professionnalisation le vicieux skyteam
vous sert a présenté hier les nouvelles
recrues et de sa section cyclisme sur
piste des athlètes réunis autour du tout
récent champion d'europe du kilomètre
quentin lafargue et puis visite au sein
du cinéma un cinéma de nouvelle
génération à mantes-la-jolie cgr propose
une expérience immersive avec des écrans
sur les côtés et découvertes dans cette
édition
c'était il ya quatre ans claire anne
fabrice grégory pierre-yves les prénoms
des cinq villes ynwa décédé sous les
balles des terroristes et font partie
des 130 victimes des attentats de paris
et de seine saint denis perpétré le 13
novembre 2015
elle nous ne les oublierons pas ne les
oublierons jamais a publié le conseil
départemental des yvelines sur son
compte twitter aujourd'hui il a été
détruit par un incendie criminel survenu
le 2 novembre à chanteloup-les-vignes le
chapiteau de l'arche a été rasé hier
mardi et les travaux de reconstruction
devraient démarrer avant la fin de
l'année ou début 2010 le chantier
devrait être financé à hauteur de 800
mille euros par le département 300000
euros par l'état et 100 mille euros par
la région ile de france
[Musique]
bientôt un an pour cette mobilisation le
17 novembre 2018 avait lieu l'acteur un
défilé jaunes un mouvement de
protestation au sein de la population à
la base contre la hausse du prix des
carburants est aussi la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat est des revendications
bien plus large aujourd'hui contre les
inégalités sociales et fiscales
quel bilan un an après on va poser la
question à mes deux invités de gilet
jaune originaire des yvelines safia
mathari et alain boucher bonsoir bonsoir
merci de votre participation alors est
ce qu'un an après la colère est toujours
présente
safia mathari oui effectivement la
colère est toujours présente
un an après puisqu'on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir obtenu les réponses
qu'on attendait on n'a même pas
l'impression d'avoir été entendu du tout
voilà pour preuve il ya un courrier qui
a été envoyé à monsieur mâcon
directement le 29 octobre par priscilla
ludo ce qui favorise y lellouche
et puis d'autres personnes demandant une
rencontre avec le président pour qu'on
puisse parler des revendications
notamment la plateforme du vrai débat
une plateforme où il ya eu plus d'un
million de votes et y ait aucune réponse
n'a été apportée à ce jour on aura
l'occasion d'en parler juste après
pourtant alain boucher on a le sentiment
en tout cas depuis la rentrée que là la
mobilisation a affaibli que l aele a
reculé de semaine en semaine
alors deux choses la première c'est que
quand vous parlez de sentiments moi par
contre alain verger des certitudes
chez la première certitude c'est que
effectivement des manifestations de rue
se sont calmés parce que un an c'est
très long mais la motivation d'un
certain nombre de gilet jaune et entière
est intacte je suis persuadé que pour le
16 et 17 novembre c'est à dire la date
anniversaire de ce début de mouvement
ça va être quelque chose de fantastique
quand je t'ai fantastique parce que la
cgt vient rejoindre le mouvement et que
la colère des gilet jaune s'est pas
seulement celle ci s'est également des
infirmières qui n'en peuvent plus les
urgences qui sont au plan de la 6e' des
pompiers qui se font caillasser matraqué
et gazés par des forces de l'ordre tout
ça c'est inadmissible ça témoigne d'un
sentiment de mal être plus générale il
ya un an si on revient aux origines de
la mobilisation pourquoi vous vous êtes
engagés tous les deux au sein de ce
mouvement
à l'embauché à écouter moi j'ai bientôt
65 ans et ça faisait des années que j'ai
oublié un petit peu dans mon coin à
savoir que quand on suit la politique on
se dit mais où est ce qu'on va dans le
mur
c'était clair et en fait j'attends des
sur le plan personnel j'attendais un
petit peu le déclic pour me motiver et
suivre j'étais dans un premier temps ou
plutôt un suiveur puis après je suis
devenu quelqu'un qui s'est investi et
qui a voulu porter des revendications
je suis pas le plus malheureux que les
choses soient claires par rapport à
d'autres j'arrive à finir les fins de
mois
mais il n'empêche que je ne travaille
pas 35 heures ou en tant qu'artisans je
travaille 50 heures si je divise mon
revenu par le nombre d'heures je ne suis
pas au smic monsieur donc est ce qu'il
est normal de travail et je dirais
presque pour la gloire finalement ça
c'est anormal
et surtout surtout ces camps en
parallèle vous avez aller 1% de la
population riche mais ultra riches dont
on a encore regarder les statistiques
qui ont pour l'année 2010 8 des revenus
qui ont encore explosé c'est à dire de
leur jeu de mémoire de 20 à 22%
on voit à vous octroyez royalement 0 3 %
d'augmentation
si vous faites le parallèle entre les
deux là il ya quelque chose qui va pas
et ça fait un an qu'on le dit et macron
un fait quoi
un show télévisé ce qu'il a appelé le
grand débat on en parlait justement à
propos de ce grand débat aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il en reste
aya réagir juste après ça fait amateur
et juste sur les origines de pourquoi
vous vous êtes engagés au sein des
gilets je me suis engagé parce qu'en
fait je suis
une citoyenne française que j'assiste
tous les jours à de l'injustice quand je
vois des personnes voilà qui travaille
35 heures mais qui ont besoin de la
prime d'activité ou des appels pour
vivre je trouve que c'est pas normal
puisqu'elles ont un métier et elle se
lève tous les jours donc il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on les assiste et j'ai
l'impression en fait qu'en france on
essaie de tirer tout le monde vers le
bas
voilà on focalise sur les personnes qui
n'ont rien et en se disant il faut leur
donner de moins en mois et on tire les
salaires vers le bas le plus bas
possible et on empêche les gens fait de
vivre dignement donc ça ça me révolte
plus tôt je me tourne vers aurélie
riront aurélie ronge bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 en réponse au
mouvement des gilets jaunes le
gouvernement a décidé de lancer le grand
débat national et il a été lancé le 15
janvier dernier
l'objectif c'était créer les conditions
d'un dialogue apaisé avec et entre les
français alors pour cela quatre thèmes
avaient été retenus la transition
écologique la fiscalité les dépenses
publiques la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
l'organisation de l'état et des services
publics alors pendant deux mois dans les
yvelines cette consultation a pris
plusieurs formes il y avait des
contributions en ligne il y avait des
cahiers de doléances en mairie et puis
il y avait également des réunions et
d'initiative locale au 15 mars 2010neuf
c'était la date de la fin du grand débat
210 réunion d'initiatives locales ont
été réalisés dans notre département
alors côté gouvernement quel a été le
bilan de ce grand débat national
alors un bilan positif et utile comme
l'avait annoncé le premier ministre
edouard philippe lors de la restitution
des contributions un sentiment qui a
également été partagé par le député
yvelinois du modem bruno myle yen qui a
notamment organisé c'est ce débat sur le
territoire le gouvernement a débloqué 10
7 milliards là je parle des mesures
d'urgence empire la deux qui sont à plus
long terme
mais 17 milliards d'euros c'est pas rien
la prime d'activité qui a été revue et
corrigée qui permet notamment aux
familles monoparentales
je pense surtout aux femmes qui
allaitent seules leurs enfants de
pouvoir bénéficier de cette crypte
d'activité jusqu'à sept fois le smic
c'est pas rien alors ce sont des mesures
d'urgence 1 comme l'a dit bruno myle yen
y en a eu d'autres
pour le pouvoir d'achat notamment la
prime exceptionnelle défiscaliser la
fameuse prime macron à 5 milliards
d'euros de baisses d'impôts en 2020 une
mesure qui devrait concerner 15 millions
de foyers les retraites de moins de 2000
euros seront également ré indexé sur
l'inflation en 2020 et je terminerai
juste avec un chiffre à 1,5 million
c'est le nombre de français qui ont pris
part aux grands débats merci aurélie
pour ces précisions une réaction vous
parliez de grands shows télévisés du
coup les réponses apportées par ce grand
débat national n'ont pas été suffisantes
à vos yeux
non mais de façon non seulement elles
n'ont pas été suffisantes mais vous
savez je viens de lire à l'instant dans
le parisien le budget de l'elysée va
être augmenté de 2 millions d'euros
nous fait on a l'impression de faire la
mendicité à côté il ya quand même deux
mondes aujourd'hui que les choses soient
claires on vit sur la même terre mais à
deux mondes parallèles et moi je ne veux
plus de ce monde parallèle je veux que
ceux pour qui un certain nombre de
citoyens ont voté et bien qu'il
représente le pays et qui représente le
plus possible ce qu'on appelait dans le
temps les masses laborieuses
aujourd'hui tout simplement des
travailleurs comme l'a dit safia des
personnes qui veulent simplement vivre
de leur travail
et il ya quelque chose d'extrêmement
dangereux dès lors qu'on donne des
allocations on devient dépendant or si
vous n'avez besoin de personne
uniquement le fruit de votre travail
vous n'êtes plus dépendants de quoi que
ce soit quelque part on peut vous faire
du chantage parce que on va vous dire
pour x raisons on va vous supprimez vos
primes on va vous supprimez vos
allocations et ça c'est terrible pour
moi c'est quelque chose de terrible
safia mathari il y à une mobilisation
qui est prévue ce week-end 16 et 17
novembre à l'occasion de cernon de la
mobilisation des gels et jaune oui
effectivement il ya une mobilisation qui
est prévu donc je vais parler de paris
puisque
c'est la plus grande ville la plus
proche de nous prescillia ludo ski
faouzi lellouche et david lee birkin qui
est avocat on déclarait une
manifestation en préfecture
malheureusement le trajet a été refusée
donc ça partait du parvis de la gare
saint lazare ont passé par boulevard
haussmann châtelet le jardin du
luxembourg montparnasse pour arriver aux
invalides sous couvert de menaces
terroristes et de plan vigipirate
renforcé
on nous demande de changer notre
parcours est d'aller dans les quartiers
populaires de paris gare de l'est donc
du punch menace terroriste a priori pour
les gens les plus pauvres
c'est assez c'est assez drôle et il faut
savoir aussi que c'est très difficile en
fait ça va être très difficile ce
week-end j'ai peur qu'il y ait des
affrontements qui est de la violence
une fois de plus du côté des forces de
l'ordre envers les citoyens
on peut plus circuler dans paris la
semaine dernière faouzi lellouche a été
convié par paris match à faire une photo
sur les champs-elysées il s'est pris une
amende pour manifestation illégale alors
qu'il était avec un journaliste
là il ya un arrêté préfectoral qui a été
pris faut savoir également que les
agents de la ratp donc c'est la nouvelle
police de l'état
ils sont autorisés ce week-end à faire
des palpations et des fruits sur les
citoyens donc vraiment on assiste à
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
inquiétant on est dans un pays libre on
est de l'an pays des droits de l'homme
et
énormément de répression on a même une
personne qui avait déclaré mobilisation
sur la place de la nation et qui s'est
retiré parce qu'il a été menacé de
représailles judiciaires par la
préfecture de police de paris
merci d'être venus en plateau un an
après le début de cette mobilisation
merci s'affirme atari et alain boucher
un mot de politique avec les élections
municipales de 2001 jeudi dernier nous
vous parlions de la désignation comme
tête de liste d'olivier paréja pour
déciderons ensemble à guyancourt
elle nous vous indiquions que le conseil
municipal siégeait toujours au sein de
la majorité petit rectificatif de sa
part olivier paréja souhaite préciser
qu'il ne fait plus partie de cette
majorité municipale lors de l'élection
du maire actuel de guyancourt françois
morton en mai dernier olivier paréja
avaient voté blanc un mot de sport et le
monde du cyclisme qui est endeuillé ce
mercredi raymond poulidor est décédé la
nuit dernière à l'âge de 83 ans l'ancien
coureur cycliste était hospitalisé
depuis le 8 octobre dernier en raison
d'une grande fatigue et même s'il n'a
pas gagné le tour de france ou coup
était considéré comme l'un des grands
cyclistes en tout cas elle jouissait
d'une grande popularité en france nous
l'avions rencontré à plusieurs reprises
dernier passage en date dans les
yvelines en mars dernier c'était à la
foire de chatou dédicaces auprès du
public et je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de son intervention et au sud
ensuite la réaction du président de la
fédération française de cyclisme qui est
basée à montigny le bretonneux
on retrace évidemment un semblant parole
l'ensemble de ma carrière et la
conversation andréens souvent avec
jacques anquetil qui est toujours
présent ce fameux duel avec jacques
anquetil et toujours imposant question
comment se fait-il
vous n'avez pas gagné plusieurs tours de
france c'est une grande tristesse et le
sentiment de perdre
vraiment quelqu'un de la famille du
cyclisme parce que raymond poulidor a
été très présent encore dans notre
cycliste travers les représentations
qu'ils pouvaient faire dans les
manifestations dans sur le tour de
france à plein d'endroits on avait de
multiples occasions de croiser vraiment
poulidor et à chaque fois de mesurer à
quel point le sport cycliste avait pu
être transcendée par par sa popularité
c'était juste incroyable de voir 40 50
ans après sa carrière
comment de partout où il passait il
était toujours aussi aimer toujours
aussi sollicités et finalement toujours
aussi connu voilà pour la disparition de
raymond poulidor cyclisme sur piste à
présent l'équipe de quentin lafargue a
présenté ses premières recrues ce mardi
soir au vélodrome nationale 2 à saint
quentin en yvelines levé ce skyteam vous
sert se prépare pour les prochaines
compétitions avec en ligne de mire un
objectif la professionnalisation
mathilde et demi et marylène iapichino
[Applaudissements]
récemment titré champion du monde du
kilomètre quentin lafargue a réuni trois
de ses coéquipiers d' équipe de france
au sein de la bce skyteam vous sert dans
l'espoir de devenir à terme la première
équipe professionnelle de cyclisme sur
piste
c'est clairement un objectif
mais on mérite en méritent tous
d'atteindre d'atteindre ce statut-là et
et on va y arriver parce que tous on a
le même même état d'esprit
à ses côtés les jeunes florian grein
beau et melvin landerneau et l'ancien
membre de l'équipe de france de bmx
passé à la piste fin 2017 quand un cas
les rangs c'est vrai qu'avec mais mes
collègues aussi on s'entend vraiment
très bien et on est une équipe mais on
est aussi des bons copains donc voilà
c'est surtout ça aussi qui qui m'a
beaucoup plu de belles recrues pour le
vélo que la d'elancourt saint quentin en
yvelines qui voit les objectifs en grand
de phase i à tokyo 2020 bien sûr il ya
plusieurs étapes avant tokyo il ya les
coupes du monde il y aura les
championnats du monde
et puis après tokyo n'a encore les
championnats de france encore des
championnats du monde pour nous conduire
jusqu'en 2024
l'apothéose doit se faire avec cette
équipe en 2024 sur les terres du décès
skyteam vous sert une équipe locomotive
pour le club qui compte 37 coureurs
engagés pour tenter de faire rayonner le
cyclisme saint quentinois dans l'univers
olympique
je reçois présent plates ou trois
invités florence courval guilels gérard
et michel v bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
vous êtes tous les trois architectes
michele vais je précise pour l'angle
locale que vous avez participé notamment
à la rénovation du quartier 17 mar mais
pas qu un à saint quentin en yvelines
dans les années 90 et vous êtes aussi
tous les trois les coauteurs c'est pour
ça que je vous reçois de ce livre ella
diehl européenne au 21e siècle en finir
avec la ville empirique la charte
d'athènes et la fracture sociale c'est
aux éditions l harmattan plus de 30 ans
d'observation de votre part sur
l'évolution et des villes du continent
et une réflexion aussi sur ce que doit
être l urbanisme européen une première
question pourquoi écrire ce livre à 3
finalement à asim 1 est ce que ça veut
dire que vous partager la même vision
sur ce sujet oui absolument nous
partageons la même vision n'est
finalement
trente ans de pratique d'architectes de
manière assez différente d'ailleurs tous
les trois mais nous partageons cette
même vision et cette même observation de
la ville en quelques mots que doit être
une ville européenne au 21ème siècle je
sais que c'est compliqué de résumer ça
en quelques mots mais quelle est votre
vision
en tout cas eh bien on produisait la
ville d'une manière traditionnelle
et puis brutalement dans les années 50
il y à une rupture et le système
rationaliste est venu changer totalement
la manière de faire la ville est
aujourd'hui nous avons notamment quand
on pense aux grands ensembles nous avons
une fracture morphologiques dans la
ville qui porte maintenant une fracture
sociale et des problèmes sociétaux
diverses des mouvements qu'on continue
de voir aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
bailleur de dans ses ouvrages vous qu'on
s'y consacre un chapitre aux grands
ensembles notamment le quartier des
tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes également à
a bondi si j'ai pas de bêtises alors ce
livre c'est plus de 30 ans villejuif
également ses plus de 30 ans
d'observation je le disais sur
l'évolution de l'urbanisme dans les
villes européennes ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que dans ce livre votre constat
n'est n'est pas bon qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné sur ses 30 ans si vous y
allez rare dans l'histoire urbaine en
fait c'est une volonté de la volonté de
d'arrêter toute la production urbaine
bimillénaire trimillénaire mais bon donc
à partir de là s'est exprimé ce système
rationalise d'en parler florence et il
faut bien dire que la forme urbaine
c'est le socle des pratiques sociales à
partir du moment où touche à la
morphologie humaine ou touche la
constitution la trame urbaine dit le
haut enfin et c'est décomposition il ya
un lien direct entre l'urbanisme
l'architecturé et l'aspect social de ces
sphères sociales sociétales bien entendu
et aujourd'hui ce que nous pouvons dire
c'est que nous ce qu'est le résultat de
nos recherches c'est que finalement le
discours politique ne prend absolument
pas ça en compte
sire que nous avons
une prise rencontre politique du
résultat de cette pratique urbaine qui
est date maintenant de 70 ans mais en
fait il ya pas de réponse
donc c'est pour cela qu'on a produit ce
document parce que nous pensons pouvoir
apporter des réponses en donnant un
système un nouveau système est ce que si
on prend l'exemple je me tourne vers
vous michel levée de la ville nouvelle
la construction de la ville nouvelle est
ce que par exemple c'est un contre
exemple de ce qui devrait se faire en
tout cas dans votre vision revient la
première partie de la ville nouvelle et
c'est pour ça aussi que je suis là
encore en grande partie c'est que les
preuves les premiers quartiers conçu
dans le cadre de la ville où elles
étaient des quartiers conçu selon la
charte d'athènes selon tous ces
principes les îlots les effets de la
séparation des fonctions et cédera petit
à petit grâce à certains surveille
certains décideurs de la ville les
choses sont arrangés mais on a du mal à
tout lâcher quoi revenir vraiment à ce
que devrait être la ville dense convient
d'expliquer dans ce conte explique dans
notre livre j'avais par contre il ya des
choses qui se font actuellement ils sont
beaucoup mieux qu'avant mais sur sage et
qui vont dans le bon sens or une
question est-ce qu d'une certaine
manière vous il y avait participé aussi
à cette mise en oeuvre de l'urbanisme
est ce que c'est un peu une forme de
remise en cause peut-être ce livre bien
entendu on ya participé
cet anneau de profession mais
aujourd'hui on compte les architectes
les maîtres d'ouvragé enfin les
décideurs continuent de participer avec
un aspect plus urbain mais c'est qu'un
aspect plus urbain le fondement
finalement théorique n'a pas changé sur
le fond c'est comprendre toujours un
terrain on travaille sur son terrain on
regarde très peu ce qui se passe
toujours on regarde on ne regarde pas le
contexte et à partir de là ça continue
de créer des problèmes
nous sommes en train aujourd'hui je vais
peut-être très loin en disant ça de
préparer les grands ensembles de demain
donc avec une spécificité des quartiers
des spécialisations qui permettent le
communautarisme et la prise de
possession d'un territoire d'où tous nos
problèmes je pense qu'on va pas
s'étendre sur ses problèmes et on les
connaît tous et on en parle
quotidiennement mais juste pour être
précis sur la charte d'athènes elle date
de 1933 et elle abordant la question de
l'extension des quartiers modernes alors
le chapitre final de
ouvrage c'est vers l'obligation d'un
nouveau mode de production urbaine
maintenant maintenant qu'il eut ce
constat que fait t'on comment ont réparé
ces erreurs du passé
c'est bien de revenir sur le constat
parce que finalement c'est le constat le
mieux partagé par tout le monde
tout le monde sait très bien la ville
dans laquelle on est bien et la ville
dans laquelle on n'est pas bien donc
c'est ce premier constat
c'était intéressant pour nous déjà de le
formaliser
ça nous a permis aussi de tirer des
enseignements de la ville et d'en tirer
des invariants qui font la ville et ceux
avec lesquels on doit tout de suite
finalement travailler si un livre qui
est destiné à tous les décideurs qui
sont actifs sur la ville c'est à dire
les élus les architectes avec les
aménageurs mais même tous les citoyens
savoir exactement dans quel contexte on
se trouve est absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui je pense que les maires ont
besoin d'avoir toutes ses connaissances
là pour prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent une pelure faire justement
ces erreurs du passé la ville européenne
au 21e siècle en finir avec la ville
empirique la charte d'athènes et la
fracture sociale c'est disponible aux
éditions l'harmattan au prix de 40 euros
merci à vous trois florence courval
bilal gérard et michel v merci merci et
co auteur de cet ouvrage
une première dans les yvelines au cinéma
cgr de mantes-la-jolie c'est une salle
immersive qui a fait son apparition une
plongée dans le film grâce à la
projection et aux panneaux sur les côtés
mais aussi grâce aux sons neuf semaines
de travaux ont été nécessaires
découverte avec mathilde et demi depuis
le 31 octobre la seule à s premium a
ouvert ses portes au cinéma cgr une
salle qui a dû passer par la case
travaux avec un budget d'un million
d'euros un coût nécessaire pour rendre
cette salle plus attractive donc voilà
comment se présente la salle donc les
fauteuils en cuir inclinable numérotées
donc ce qui vous permet de réserver à
l'avancé notamment maintenant si vous
voulez par exemple réserver pour star
wars qui a lieu en décembre pouvez déjà
réserver votre place et vous aurez votre
place du groupe sera attitré
en plus de ça vous avez donc une
personne un agent d'accueil qui est
dédié à la salle qui vous accueille dans
la salle donc pour vous placer ce sera à
toutes les séances vraiment donc comme
ça au moins vous serez pas perdu
star wars épisode 9 la reine des neiges
2 ou encore doumandji next level seront
diffusés dans cette salle un peu
particulière une immersion dans le film
avec des écrans sur les côtés de la
salle et des spots derrière les
spectateurs pour créer une ambiance
visuelle la pâte salle près même en
yvelines ça change en fait vous vivez
vraiment une véritable expérience comme
on l'a dit immersif cinéma expérience
c'est vraiment pour être en immersion
quelque chose voilà vous vivez le film
notamment au niveau de l'image du son et
des panneaux a ici merci vraiment vous
êtes dans le film effet apporte quelque
chose pour voir un film dans cette salle
il faut compter entre 2 et 4 euros de
plus que pour un film dans une salle
normale en ce qui nous concerne leur
rapport qualité prix non je vais voir
pour découvrir aujourd'hui la première
fois ça dépendrait du film mais oui pour
être un peu comme à la maison
un rapport qualité prix qui divise le
cinéma cgr vise un public jeune
notamment avec les films qui seront
bientôt à l affiche dans cette nouvelle
salle avant de vous laisser jusqu'au 23
novembre ce sont les l'udid les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines vous font découvrir des jeux de
société des murder party avait aussi des
escape game le rendez-vous débuté ce
week-end avec une intrigue qui se
déroulait à la commanderie mélanie poker
je suis assistant du professeur depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois
oui mais voilà des plans de cette
invention ont disparu alors l'assistant
du professeur a besoin d' aide la
famille d'achats frier à 30 minutes pour
les trouver il participe à un escaping
ya pas de compétences particulières en
escrime fouette observateurs faut
fouiller et surtout il faut s'organiser
en équipe ya des moments où à rechercher
fouiller tout seul mais dès qu'on est
bloqué pour bien penser à se regrouper
en équipe se poser des questions c'est
chose faite pour la famille guillon
courtoises avec un record à la clé ils
ont moins de 24 minutes a trouvé ce
qu'il cherchait c'est un bon moyen de
créer une bonne cohésion familiale ne
travailler en équipe
c'est
évident on est on est aidé on est
soutenus donc non ça va ont passé un
moment en famille et c'est la première
fois aussi que j'en fais un escape game
organisé dans le cadre des lui dit dave
les jeux avaient pris possession de la
commanderie
dans une autre salle on découvrait des
jeux de société nous on essaie de jouer
ensemble en famille est donc là bas on
en profite pour venir voir d'autres
types de jeu qu'on n'aurait pas nous à
la maison voir ce qu'il nous plaît et
tester des choses c'est trop bien vasque
un fonds fait beaucoup de jeu et on
s'amuse et puis là je ne sers un escape
from c'était le jeu revient en force
sous toutes ses formes placer la forme
de jeux vidéo aussi juteux société il ya
énormément de création de jeux vidéo
aujourd'hui nous avons d'ailleurs
présents sur les les événements à
villepreux et au muy med des créateurs
de jeu l'élu dit dave continue jusqu'au
23 novembre à saint quentin en yvelines
peut être un moyen de compléter sa
lettre au père noël
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi ne bougeait pas dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
nous parlerons ce soir et des repas
végétariens imposé au moins une fois par
semaine dans les cantines scolaires
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]